the mcu has seen its fair share of death
over the course of its many films with
many characters uttering dramatic final
words packed with thematic meaning
these are the last words of every fallen
mcu hero
and villain starting with the most
memorable the first major villain to
fall in the mcu was obadiah stain the
antagonist and the first iron man
stain is introduced as tony stark's
lifelong friend and business advisor but
as the film goes on it becomes clear
that he is unhappy that tony has
survived his trip to the desert
latching onto tony's own arc reactor
technology he becomes the iron monger
hell-bent on killing tony and reclaiming
the company for himself
while his actual mostly forgettable last
words come a second later when he tells
tony to hold still so he can shoot him
it's the words leading up to that moment
that foreshadowed tony's recurring
struggle within the mcu
trying to read the world of weapons you
gave me this best one ever
and now i'm gonna kill you with it
in many ways tony stark spends the rest
of his time in the mcu
grappling with his own legacy trying to
use his brain to protect the world even
as his hubris keeps causing problems
it took three iron man films before one
of the characters most famous comic book
villains the mandarin was finally
brought to the mcu
sort of for much of the film the
mandarin appears as a terrorist in a
series of video messages which later
turn out to be the work of a drug-addled
actor hired by the film's real
mastermind
vengeful scientist aldrich killian as
the film progresses
tony stark learns that killian and his
extremist compound are the real threats
and the two clash in a fiery showdown at
the end of the movie before killian
finally dies he shouts
i am the mandarin
it's an amusing tease for what's to come
since neither villain of iron man 3 is
actually the real mandarin
marvel revealed in 2019 that the real
mandarin will be making his debut
in shanghai and the legend of the ten
rings groot may only say three words
throughout most of guardians of the
galaxy
but through his actions he proves
himself to be a loyal friend a kind hand
and a powerful warrior when his friends
are threatened this all reaches its apex
in the climatic scene of the movie when
the guardians are trapped on a crashing
spaceship that's set to send them to
their deaths
groot forms a leafy cocoon around his
friends to cushion the impact despite
knowing it will kill him
when his best friend rocket tries to
stop him the talking tree simply says
[Music]
it's a powerful moment of unity and love
and an emotional farewell to the
original group
guardians of the galaxy writer and
director james gunn has confirmed that
the current groot in the mcu is the old
groot son
meaning those three words were a
permanent devastating goodbye
in 2015 age of ultron introduced two new
members to earth's mightiest heroes
wanda and pietro maximoff the twins were
initially set up as villains until they
saw the error of their ways and joined
the avengers to battle ultron at the end
of the film
while wanda has since gone on to become
an increasingly vital member of the mcu
writer and director joss whedon chose
ultron's final battle to prove that
superheroes aren't always safe
to protect hawkeye and the civilian
child he's holding pietro otherwise
known as quicksilver runs in front of a
spray of bullets
when hawkeye sees the sacrifice he just
made the young speedster responds
you didn't see that coming
[Music]
it's both an echo of the character's
earlier boastful line
and a nod to the audience who really
didn't see that coming
avengers age of ultron spends a lot of
time focusing on the hubris of
superheroes and in particular the hubris
of tony stark
at the start of ultron in his efforts to
build quote a suit of armor around the
world
tony accidentally creates ultron a
murderous
artificial intelligence that decides the
key to saving earth is
actually destroying humanity after stark
and the rest of the avengers managed to
fight ultron off newly created member
vision is left to dispatch the last
remaining ultron bot
after vision speaks admiringly of humans
ultron tells him
you're unbearably naive vision
acknowledges the truth of ultron's
statement
by admitting that he was literally born
yesterday before destroying ultron for
good
when yondu was first introduced in
guardians of the galaxy he was depicted
as a cruel and domineering figure in
peter's life
by guardians of the galaxy vol 2 though
we learned that yondu actually saved
peter's life as a child by not
delivering him to his real father ego
after yondu learned that ego was killing
all of his children from around the
galaxy
though he spent most of his life hiding
it yondu loved peter like a son and
that's something he finally confesses
during an act of self-sacrifice in
volume 2.
before yondu's death he finally
expresses his affection for peter
i'm sorry i didn't do none of it right
i'm damn lucky you're my
yondu's act of heroism also helped to
bring about his own redemption
represented by an honorable ravager
funeral at the end of the film
in finally declaring his love for his
adoptive son yondu made guardians of the
galaxy's message of the importance of
found family
even clearer black panther's eric
killmonger is wakandan by birth
but was raised in the united states
after the death of his disgraced father
he grew up to become a smart fierce
warrior and saw firsthand the injustices
of the world around him
it was those injustices that he sought
to remedy by seizing control of wakanda
intending to use its vast wealth and
technology to reshape the world through
conquest
this culminates in a showdown between
killmonger and t'challa
in which the two men are very evenly
matched despite his grudging respect for
his cousin t'challa ultimately defeats
killmonger and walks him out to see a
wakandan sunset before he dies
t'challa even offers to try and heal
killmonger
which is when eric gives the last in a
long line of profound observations
just bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage
odin has a complicated relationship with
the mcu
and a particularly complicated
relationship with his sons
thor and loki by the time of thor
ragnarok he's been deposed by his son
forced into exile on earth and is aware
that the daughter he'd hidden away is
coming to wipe out his kingdom
still in his final scene odin shows a
lot of wisdom and perspective
talking to his sons he makes the vital
point that asgard is not a place
but a people and that thor and loki must
do whatever they can to lead them
as he sits on a cliff in norway pointing
at the ocean he tells his sons he loves
them before saying
remember this place
home with that odin fades away leaving
thor with the burden of his long legacy
in the years since thor loki has been
everything from an all-out villain to a
redeemed hero
it's been quite a journey but it all
came to an end at the beginning of
avengers infinity war
when the god of mischief's bag of tricks
finally ran out
after trying to deploy one of his
enchanted blades against thanos loki
finds himself with the mad titan's hand
around his throat
with no more options and no more tricks
up his sleeves loki has no choice but to
dangle helplessly as thanos strangles
him
he does however get in one last dig
this attempt to bruise thanos ego turns
out to be ironic since by the end of
infinity war thanos is practically a god
thanks to all of those infinity stones
of course after the events of avengers
end game marvel tells us there's another
version of loki zipping around the
cosmos but it was still tragic to lose
the original trickster who had come
so far gamora had a rough childhood to
put it mildly
after half the people on her planet were
slaughtered by thanos the mad titan
adopted her as his daughter
then came years of torturous training
and ruthless manipulation that she was
only able to break when she left thanos
for the guardians
sadly when father and daughter meet
again in avengers infinity war all of
her pain comes rushing back
on vormir thanos learns he has to
sacrifice something he loves if he's
ever to get his hands on the soul stone
at first when gamora sees tears in
thanos eyes she thinks it's because he
knows his lack of love has become his
downfall
then she realizes he's weeping for her
and protests
this isn't love thanos apologizes but
still throws his daughter to her death
he gets the soul stone confirming that
he did indeed love gamora in his own
abusive and twisted way
of course while the original gamora died
we'll still get to see more of her since
the 2014 gamora is still alive and well
following the events of avengers end
game
though he's an android and she's a human
vision and wanda maximoff still
managed to fall in love sometime between
captain america civil war and avengers
infinity war
the pair bonded thanks to their shared
experience as outsiders and their mutual
struggle of coming to terms with powers
they don't fully understand
however the two are torn apart in
avengers infinity war when
in an attempt to save the universe from
thanos vision asks wanda to destroy the
mind stone in his head and kill him
as wanda prepares to do the unthinkable
vision tells her she could never hurt
him and that he just feels her
moments before she shatters the infinity
stone keeping him alive vision whispers
his last words
[Music]
not only is vision willing to die but he
is willing to absolve and reassure wanda
as he goes
he doesn't blame her in fact he's
grateful for her
original avenger natasha romanov has
always been a woman looking for
redemption
as she put it i got red in my ledger
i'd like to wipe it out when she is sent
to vormir in avengers end game she
finally sees the opportunity to wipe out
that red once and for all offering to
sacrifice herself so that the avengers
can claim the soul stone
the only problem natasha's best friend
clint barton also has some sins to atone
for and the two end up
battling for who will make the ultimate
sacrifice as clint makes a last-ditch
effort to save natasha she asks him to
let her go
assuring him
[Music]
natasha may be the first of the original
six to die but it's on her terms and
with a clear ledger
avengers endgame mostly focuses on the
surviving members of the team traveling
through time to steal the infinity
stones in an effort to undo what
happened in infinity war
by the final act of the film the
avengers have successfully reversed
thanos's snap
but find themselves battling a 2014
version of thanos who traveled to the
future
for a moment towards the end of the
battle it seems thanos has won yet again
and he declares i am
inevitable
[Music]
when he snaps though nothing happens
because tony stark had sneakily grabbed
the stones himself
it's then that the godfather of the mcu
utters his own final words
iron man tony snaps and thanos fades
away but the power of the stones is too
much for tony's human body to handle
and he dies together their intertwining
final words reveal what happens when a
reluctant hero is willing to make the
ultimate sacrifice for the good of
others and what happens when an arrogant
villain is convinced of his own
righteousness
spider-man far from home spends a lot of
its run time with a dual purpose
it advances peter parker's story but it
also explains the way the mcu looks
following the events of endgame
and of course the death of tony stark
these themes are personified in quentin
beck a seemingly benevolent figure who
turns out to be a disgruntled former
stark employee
beck uses his mastery of illusion
technology to cast himself as mysterio
a hero who is actually a madman
hell-bent on seizing tony stark's legacy
though peter initially believes he's on
the right side he finally uncovers
beck's scheme
and in the resulting showdown beck is
killed as he breathes his last he warns
peter
people need to believe
and nowadays they'll believe anything
this is a statement that proves
prophetic the end of the film reveals
that mysterio's team released a doctored
video that makes spider-man look like
beck's murderer
of all the marvel franchises that kill
off major characters thor seems to have
the highest body count
in the first film the ice giant lauffy
tells a comatose odin that he hopes he's
still aware of his surroundings because
he wants the all-father to know
your death came at the hand
of laughing
however laufey is then immediately
killed by his own biological son loki as
proof of the trickster's loyalty to his
adopted father odin
thor the dark world then claims the life
of thor's mother friega
when malacath shows up looking for the
ether he demands to know its location
before the dark elf kills her friega
defiantly says
i'll never tell you then later in the
same film malakath himself dies while
declaring
the ether cannot be destroyed but when
it comes to asgardians kicking the
bucket it doesn't get any grizzlier than
thor ragnarok all of the warriors three
meet their fates at the hands of hella
when she returns to claim her throne
when hella first appears in asgard
volstagg asks
who are you what are you doing in
response he's stabbed to death
fandral only manages a guttural scream
before he's killed although zachary levi
says he did film some final words which
were cut from the finished film my last
words
in the marvel universe work for us
and finally hogan gets the most poetic
final words before being impaled
telling hella go back to whatever cave
you crept out of
you evil demons the deaths don't stop
here though
toward the end of the final battle
scourge switches sides and sacrifices
himself proclaiming
for asgard
as for hello when she realizes loki has
resurrected sir tur
her last word is a stunned
lastly in avengers infinity war thor's
best friend heimdall is killed for
activating the bifrost sending the hulk
to earth with his final words while
steve rogers and bucky barnes both
managed to survive decades after the
world thought them dead the villains of
the captain america franchise haven't
been so lucky
in captain america the winter soldier
steve discovers that former hydra
operative arnhem zola is still around as
a living computer
before he's destroyed by a shield
missile zola tells steve
we are both of us out of time
then there's alexander pierce the world
security council member who turns out to
have been a secret hydra operative for
decades
as he dies after being defeated by
stephen nick fury he declares
later in captain america civil war
before the hydra traitor brock rumlow
detonates the bomb that kills him he
taunts steve by bringing up bucky
telling him that bucky said
please tell rogers when you gotta go
you gotta go
and you're coming with me at the end of
iron man 2 as ivan vonko detonates the
army of drones around him the russian
villain looks at tony stark and simply
says
you lose
[Music]
vonko is wrong but the incident leaves
tony once again
questioning his place as a hero in black
panther secondary villain ulysses claw
meets his end at the hands of eric
killmonger
just before claw dies killmonger pulls
down his lip and reveals a wakandan war
dog tattoo
at that the arm smuggler expresses
amused surprise
telling killmonger uh to think i saw you
as some crazy american
then there's darren cross the villain
from ant-man who put on the yellowjacket
armor and launched a full-scale attack
against
scott lang in his daughter cassie's
bedroom just before his death cross
turns to cassie lang and declares
sorry sweetheart you have to help daddy
pay for his mistakes
this line is a nod to lang's criminal
past as well as cassie's own possible
superhero
future the mcu is full of cosmic and
magical figures and while more keep
joining the mix some have fallen for
good
ronin the accuser the hammer-wielding
villain of guardians of the galaxy was
killed after facing off against
star-lord and his friends
before he died he expressed shock when
peter quill and the other guardians were
able to hold an infinity stone crying
immortal
this foreshadowed the revelation and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 that peter
was actually half celestial
his father ego the living planet had
passed his power onto him
ego planned to use that power to take
over the universe but peter gave up his
god-like status dwarting ego's plans and
leading ego to warn him
if you kill me you'll be just like
everybody else
of course that's what peter wanted all
along in doctor strange the ancient one
contemplated the imminent arrival of her
own death in a rather poetic way
saying she thought she'd be ready but
when the time came she surprised herself
look at me stretching one moment out
into a thousand
just so that i can watch the snow in
captain marvel the kree scientist marvel
nodded to carol danvers heroic destiny
before she died
you gotta save them without me see who
cow now i gotta
blow this engine before they find
they're doing right
now this set up both carol's future with
the skrulls and her own powers which
came from that same engine check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you